meine erste frage ist heute in die runde
14 haben sie ihr leben eigentlich auch
schon umgestellt
nein richtig umgestellt natürlich noch
nicht weil ich einfach immer sparsam mit
den ressourcen umgehen also bei mir zu
hause wird das licht ausgeschaltet
bei mir zuhause wird keine aircondition
laufen gelassen wenn die fenster offen
sind in warmen ländern hier in
deutschland braucht man ja gar keine
klimaanlage hier habe ich gar keine
klimaanlage also
mit den ressourcen
sparsam umzugehen haben wir gelernt von
kinder auf und das ist das hat man
irgendwann in den knochen und dadurch
würde ich sagen sind wir zuhause öko
faschisten das ist ein gutes wort vela
wir sind bei dir aus
ja also ich habe tatsächlich
einmal sagen kann das privileg das glück
ein kamin zu haben und ich habe
schwiegereltern die die ganze zeit im
winter mit holz heizen nützlich und habe
da jetzt schon mehr holz gesichert ich
weiß nicht ob das nun besonders
umweltgerecht ist oder nicht aber wer
weiß was kommt und aus diesem grunde
kann man sagen ja ein bisschen
umgestiegen bin ich das schon frau
wagenknecht sowie präpariert für
schlechte zeiten wir haben es ja gerade
leider im film nicht gehört aber herr
scholz hat ja eigentlich alle weil sie
darauf eingestimmt dass alle auf
unterhaken sollen und dass man sich
schon mal auf schwere zeiten einstellen
soll ich finde das wirklich zynisch also
die die bundestag sitzen das schließt
mich ein die können natürlich auch
schwere zeiten sich mehr oder minder
leisten also wenn der gaspreis
explodiert und jetzt empfohlen wird die
leute sollen mal vielleicht 2000 euro
zurücklegen für die nachzahlung und
vielleicht sind auch 4000 okay im
bundestagsabgeordneter kann das aber wer
kann das sonst also ich finde das
wirklich unverantwortlich wie die
regierung sehenden auges in eine
gasknappheit hineinläuft die nicht sein
müsste also das muss man immer wieder
sagen das ist ja hausgemacht das sind ja
die sanktionen der eu und der in die
reaktion und russlands darauf und ich
meine das wurde alles gemacht weil man
gesagt hat wie berbalk damals wir wollen
russland ruinieren und wir sehen jetzt
wir holen hier nicht russland wir
ruinieren unser wohlstand wir ruinieren
unsere industrie und russland hat sogar
höhere einnahmen als je zuvor also die
sanktion von putins taschen und hier im
land sind die portemonnaies leer und ich
finde das urteil können wir gleich weil
es ja auch die these die sie heute
mitgebracht haben aber freiheit meint er
aber warum sollen wir russland ruinieren
es hat ja wohl ein grund wir wollen ja
menschen schützen also ich habe könne
leider keine wärmepumpe machen weil es
bei mir nicht geht ganz sicher hieß es
ich kann meine ölheizung
subventioniert bekommen wenn ich auf gas
umstellen das hätte mich dann 15.000
euro gekostet die umstellung auf gas
gott sondern gab es nicht gemacht ich
habe auch einen kamin einen offenen
kamin aber auch das ist problematisch
weil die ganzen emissionen das war ja
gesicht und auch im gespräch also dass
unterhaken denke ich wir bei uns einfach
mal sehen und wenn man von den leuten
sprechen die mehr geld haben im
bundestag dann kann man da vielleicht
ein bisschen unter hagen indem man
menschen die rechts und links wurden da
einfach ein bisschen die oberhaut nannte
hartmann ich hoffe es ist in ordnung man
kann ja auch nachschauen wie viele
bücher sie verkauft haben sie 14 ja auch
als vermögende frau können sie denn dann
nachvollziehen dass frau wagenknecht
sagt na ja vielleicht auch sie haben gut
reden und vielleicht auch frau nadija
was also ich du ja persönlich was ich
versuche ich habe mal versucht vor
jahren etwas ins laufen zu bringen dass
sie ein kind an der hand nehmen das
wurde dann in der
baden-württembergischen stiftung
aufgenommen ich meine es aber auch
wirklich so ich meine jeder von uns hat
nachbarn hat eine alte frau vielleicht
als nachbarin oder hat kinder als
nachbarn und jeder von uns sieht wenn es
gut geht und wenn es schlecht geht und
es tut uns nicht so wahnsinnig weh wenn
wir einfach dann da hingehen und
denjenigen wirklich unterhaken und sagen
kann ich irgendwo helfen das ist nämlich
eigentlich eine christliche
nächstenliebe
pflichten die karten sie vollkommen
recht aber das ist nicht die politik
muss dem ganzen volk helfen und es
einfach ganz richtig was die frau
wagenknecht sagt unverantwortlich dass
wir sehenden auges in die verarmung der
80 millionen bürger hat deutschland
untersagt der chef politiker der
außenminister und ein der
wirtschaftsminister sagt er wird jetzt
weniger duschen
weniger ja auch wenn wir alle reiniger
genau es ist einerseits zynischen weil
damit werden wir das problem nicht in
den griff kriegen deutschland ist ein
industrieland wir haben jetzt 40 jahre
wirtschaftlichen aufschwung und den
machen wir in wenigen jahren einfach
news will ich kaputt weil wir eben die
falsche entscheidung das sehe ich nicht
so sie haben ja gehen der ig haben ja
den größten waldbesitzer den größten
waldbesitzer in deutschland ich meine da
kommt ja wirklich was zusammen
vorsitz der deutschlands ist der staat
und sie bei gemeinden sind sony 2 1 in
hannover kommen weit weit hinterher wir
sind waldbauern und wir müssen hart
arbeiten und dass wir geld verdient der
staat und die gemeinden und die kommunen
können es sich leisten weil sehr mit
steuergeld an tieren dass sie so nicht
genau jeden pfennig umdrehen müssen das
ist bei uns privaten nicht der fall wir
müssen jeden pfennig und drinnen und das
arbeiten im wald wird uns immer
schwieriger gemacht weil die auflagen
die aus brüssel kommen was dürfen wir
ernten was dürfen wir pflanzen wie viele
mitarbeiter müssen wir mindestens haben
was für maschinen dürfen überhaupt den
einsatz kommen sie können sich nicht
vorstellen mit wie vielen beschränkungen
und auflagen wir arbeiten müssen und das
ist für den privaten faust extrem schwer
das glaube ich sofort wie viele
mitarbeiter haben sie denn im forst
haben insgesamt 50
insgesamt versorgt es gab es gerade die
familienunternehmen hier die haben auch
gerade eine große tagung gehabt in
berlin und da waren wir mental hilft
unternehmen dabei ganz genau da war
beispielsweise kupfer mit trigema dabei
da war die frau doktor schmiede dabei
die hat die vielen schmieder kliniken
jahr 2800 angestellte da war auch dabei
als
arbeitgeberpräsident und und die sagten
dann okay unser problem ist energie gebe
ich ihnen recht aber unser problem sind
eben auch die arbeitskräfte die müssen
irgendwie rein kommen und bisher haben
wir schon so vieles geschafft auch das
schaffen wir noch also diese diese diese
schlecht sehr reif scheint mir für den
mittelständischen unternehmen der
familie betrieben allerdings noch nicht
so frauen ganz viele unternehmen die
ganz große angst haben da sieht man
wieder je nachdem in dem entspricht